greetings from podcast village Monday
the 9th of December the church is
brought to you by manscape the best and
below-the-belt grooming christmas is
coming if you're here to unwrap your
present you got to trim that tree dog
get manscape
they created the only tool you need to
shave your ballsack it's called the
lawnmower 2.0 for a reason
they grew weight at one point on why
cousin a [ __ ] compared to the 2.0 and
they upgraded the trimmer with a skin
save technology for you mow mows in the
back it means it won't knit or snag your
nutsack now the church family can get
20% off your first door when you use
cold church at manscape this makes a
perfect Christmas present all of the
perfect package which I'll talk about at
the end of the show with cold church and
they'll throw in a free travel bag when
you use promo code Church CH you are CH
that's manscape Tom use promo code
church for 20% off your first order the
church is also brought to you by Netflix
new podcasts behind the Irishmen you've
heard about Martin Scorsese's epic movie
the Irishmen starring De Niro Pacino Joe
Pesci and my brother from a different
mother Sebastian Maniscalco is crazy Joe
Gallo if you haven't seen the Irishman
yet go watch it listen to me it's a
tremendous movie I don't care what
anybody tells you now do me a favor the
first two episodes out and the final
episode is coming out next Monday 2:16
spoiler alert watch the Irishmen on
Netflix before you listen to the podcast
trust me search for behind the Irishmen
on Apple products Spotify stitcher
pocket cast or wherever else you listen
to podcast watch the movie then go
behind the Irish myth kick this meal
League it's a beautiful day to be alive
Andrew what's going on brother are you
how are you great to see you it's been a
minute
you know that's where I'm drinking the
coffee you're trying to wake up to you I
love it I love the car you pulled up in
it's the second one of those I've had
you
like it yeah I love it wait okay take
this off yeah you do it I like you in
the music through it okay yeah the other
one I kept for like 10 years you know
and then I just got another one cuz it's
just you you know how in Hollywood you
know God forbid you know if you're
anybody if you don't have the Mercedes
or the Acura or the [ __ ]
and I got nothing Mercedes is the I
gotta say it's it it's a machine it's
the greatest car on earth but the
Challenger is just [ __ ] Cola and
that's why I got it what year is that
one it's basically um it's it a nineteen
that night no no I'm just saying I think
it's a nineteen twenty nineteen yeah
only not before yeah
the other one I bought like ten years
ago you know and they don't change a
much you know it's just like the perfect
car just for you and you check like
there's a back seat but nobody's ever
back there you know what I mean and it's
and I never went for little sports cause
it's a big car that's what I like about
it I Drive I don't give a [ __ ] about
BMWs convertibles nothing I Drive a
super one since 87 why stop now
no you know what it's what you like
that's what I'm saying you know I've
actually had I like a cowboy you know I
like the new SDS Cadillac you know
that's a good call but I don't want to
drive 800 amando you know but well I
like the Escalade the shorter Escalade
is like muscley you know and I mean
bigger can't see well but yes a I can't
see everything's falling off I can see I
could never I had a truck four years in
Colorado and the right side always had
Dennis I had more dents on the right
side yeah I don't know what it is about
the [ __ ] I well I drove the I drove
the truck for years but I just them into
this car you know and it just feels good
like I'm not like a one minute up guy
even though I got the call like a year
ago you know it doesn't get old to me in
30 seconds where you treat it like
garbage and you don't wash it and you
know I'm into it like the whole time I
had that other one I was into it look
that this means anything I just you know
really appreciate the things I have you
know I don't it just doesn't get up what
what why are you looking at me like that
and it's happy you're here what kind of
car you drive I Drive a Jetta I wish I
had your car
you know no but I'm just saying I but
you let your call not as much as you do
I just had it just a car no I really do
I like decided I was screaming at the
[ __ ] salesman because I thought I'd
maybe get a charger so I went to the
same place I didn't even realize in
Vegas there's a Dodge dealership like
three blocks from me so I go all the way
on the east side where I got the first
challenger and the guy and I go I'm
thinking maybe I'll get the charger you
know and but you know I have to say and
I'm thinking that because it's four-door
so if I want to go out with my sons
you know they sit in the back obviously
so um so I could of get in the back I
hit my head you know cuz now what they
do they make that lower and they bring
the glass the back of the window I can't
fall over your head
so senator salesman I go why would they
do that so if it's sunny out you're just
burning the top of your head like why
won't they fit he goes well you know I
just sell it
I go no but you're the [ __ ] salesman
you know and you have no answer for me
you know then I sit in the front and I
go is the seat smaller than the
Challenger and he goes well I don't know
I got you ever sit in the Challenger and
he goes yeah go you ever sit in a
charger you know and he's going yeah I
go and you can't feel the difference
you're gonna stand there and just
[ __ ] lie to me now you know you don't
know why the glass is the way it is you
don't know why the [ __ ] seat is the
way it is you don't even have a color
I'm looking for but yet you're telling
me we'll give you a good deal on what on
something I don't want is that what
you're gonna tell me
now and he's like well you know we could
talk to the bike go talk to the boss
about what like oh there's not a car
here that I want he goes well we could
get you any color that you want and I'm
going there's not if do you understand I
go a car is an impulse buy I drove in
here I got in a certain mood I go
alright it's time to trade this one out
I'll get a new one maybe to charge you
which makes [ __ ] little baby seats
they go because it's a sports car I go
and what the [ __ ] is the Challenger and
I'm really yelling at the guy I go with
the Challenger beacon if we were in a
[ __ ] court of law with the Challenger
be considered a sports car and it goes
yeah I support no not suppose you know
this is what the guy go it either is or
it isn't and he goes yeah it's a sports
car go see you answered the question so
you know I'm not buying the charger
because it's made out of [ __ ] it's just
a glass car as far as I'm concerned it's
gonna burn people's heads off in the
middle of the [ __ ] desert they go and
you don't have a challenger it you got
all [ __ ] colors no [ __ ] sky roof
where I could open up the sky roof is
that what it's called some sunroof this
one have a sunroof this one that you
driving now yes okay
my one it if that's what I was looking
for you know so then I'm told by a
friend of mine in Vegas they go there's
a Dodge dealership two blocks from you
for the most part and you're going a
half hour the other way so go to the
other place and there it is one of a
kind with the shaker the whole [ __ ]
thing and I go that's the car just give
it to me you know and take this and
that's the story of the Challenger
because I know you like stories but I
really get mad at salesmen when they try
to [ __ ] me cuz even years ago a
Cadillac I don't know if they did this
I made but I went to buy an Escalade EXT
at the time you know the square back so
I'm looking at the backseat
once again the salesman they make like
they know everything till you got a
question you know how the front heads
the captain seat right nice high you
know protect you so the back doesn't
have that right and I go with the
highest seat even in the regular one the
not the XD I go where's the high you
know backs on the seats
well no it's got the little thing i coat
the little thing for what when you stop
short kids could just break their necks
that the head is above that [ __ ] like oh
so cadillac is just gonna [ __ ] you the
adults count but the kids [ __ ] them
right [ __ ] anybody in the back if you
happen to have [ __ ] fender bender and
your net brakes off you know i go is
that what you're telling me you know for
the three cents more it'll take to build
the [ __ ] car for the ninety or a
hundred grand that you want for the car
you don't get to support your neck i got
a worry who's in the back [ __ ] seat
if somebody bashes into me because you
said i [ __ ] them [ __ ] grandma and
grandpa right [ __ ] you know I just
[ __ ] hate people because as I go on
with life just I realize how everybody's
full of [ __ ] like like did you see me
walk in here with any friends no do you
know why why cuz there are no [ __ ]
you know my mother taught me that when I
was very young you know and of course
you got to read between the lines you
know in life you go oh this is a friend
right you know sort of you know you know
till they ask me to buy them a car and
then they're not a friend anymore you
know then I just eliminate them from my
[ __ ] life cuz I don't know anybody
any [ __ ] thing you know whatever I
got I [ __ ] took in my life
you know and you know people even say to
me like yeah I got to do this where am i
performing artist and okay which is the
I just got to say it on the 10 and then
also next week the 17th and 8th
that the stand and I'm supposed to say
that you know they asked me would you
say that I'm happy then no I'm glad to
see you yeah like you know even when I
said well you know I could do you know
Joe Diaz he's a buddy of mine you are a
friend you know what I mean but you not
a friend I'm with every day so it's like
a pleasure to see you you don't call me
up and go give me money I did cause you
know two days no no I'm saying to give
you this you know what I mean you know
and I'm not you know this is mine I took
the time to buy this in Baker that's a
good choice you know with no cuz I got a
brand-new girlfriend for the last like
four months now right which I'll tell
you about Eleanor gotta for me write
this and um and so on the way back from
Vegas I stopped at Baker you know and it
was like these sand storms like she
couldn't believe you know what are we
doing here and I go no you don't
understand the candy they have at this
particular place and she goes what candy
what is with you with the candy and I
look at her I go what's with you you
know just cause I'm over 20
I'm not allowed candy anymore there's a
cut-off date they get the big tootsie
rolls they got the they get the hot
tamales in the box see what Hot Tamale
tried to do was put it in little bags
like Eminem bags you know so I stopped
[ __ ] buying them like you belong in a
box you know like good and plenty good
and plenty don't come in a [ __ ] bag
comes in a box the way it should like
Mike and Ike right with the multi
flavors right the hot tamales you think
they didn't go back to the box because
they saw her I wasn't buying them so I
got to touch zeros she goes I can't
believe what you're walking the 5-year
olds coming in this gas station and not
walking out with this much candy and
then I showed her in the car had a line
everything up with the Mentos and you
know like push you got the Mentos then
the tootsie roll then a Mentos and a
tootsie roll you see there's an order
you know then then the the bubble gum
goes on the bottom part
then the boxes go on the top shelf okay
you know like the Hot Tamales the good
and plenty the Mike and Ikes and she's
going you're a man I go why can't a man
like candy in the same it's what I like
she goes well you know I know you told
me sugar level yet like like I had
diabetes for half a minute like
everybody's getting you know I have that
like that's the hot like god forbid you
don't have diabetes you're not part of
the in-crowd that's why I stay the [ __ ]
out of Florida
they're all just the walking [ __ ] oh my
god yeah yeah you know I mean I gotta go
there too this week but you know that's
that's alright you know yeah I don't
even know the name of the place I'm just
going and doing it and I'm getting the
[ __ ] out of it because I got the [ __ ]
relatives calling from eight months ago
okay eight months ago they're calling
you know are we gonna hang out are you
gonna come over why so you could bring
the neighbor over five minutes after I'm
there I'm never going over you you know
eight much and and I tried to explain
with the texting I go I can't talk about
a a one night gig I'm doing eight months
from now I don't like to think about
when I got a travel I'm sure you're the
same way I don't want to think about it
I'm what's in front of me all you care
is it that's right front of me and then
once you're on stage you're home
whatever you want Rhys me crazier than a
friend of mine calling me going hey I
see you're gonna be injured like today
know call me and go hey I see you're
gonna be in Jersey in August would
definitely coming it audiences me the
[ __ ] off I called the front of my last
week I have I have a certain thing when
I go on the road that whenever I have
bad luck I don't know what I do that I
have bad luck but every time when I go
to town to something like hometown
somebody's mother dies I've never seen
anything like this so I get these people
will call me and they'll go will come
and I bought 20 tickets will go on a
dinner at Spago's whatever they dig
the whole lineup of what they're doing
then the day of a two o'clock
I'm going to come home only computer so
I'll get the text messages I'll get a
text
my mother has dementia and she left the
house and got on a bicycle and fell off
the bicycle what are you talking about
the last time I was in Atlantic City
this guy tortured me for a [ __ ] I'll
stress factory I was just act Ober 24th
tortured me for a year
I'm coming I'm coming like what 20
ticket the day of my father the bag
broke so he can't piss every time I go
home I have they call you a year before
they are these relatives are just people
that dear friend I love him to death but
I don't you try to you want to let them
know like listen I don't really give a
[ __ ] about next August like I'm not even
so yeah I'm thinking don't they have a
job don't want to get up I was careers
they have everything but they think like
what you do is just a joke not like it's
work up there right you know what I mean
they don't understand like your burning
out your brain you'd my face out on our
they get it now you know they get it now
my van a little of them why my relatives
they never got it they never got it
like when I wait you know cuz after they
they don't get the response from me they
get to my sister okay
and my sister tells them like this is
for the last like two and a half years I
was like single so my sister would say
if he hangs out with you but a time he's
done all the girl he wants to meet girls
he wants to have a good time he doesn't
want to sit there and go so what's new
who gives a [ __ ] what's know I don't
care what's know as long as they're all
healthy and happy
god bless stay to [ __ ] away from me
who's left in Florida you know I got
plenty there I got Palance you talk yeah
yes
cousins and it's just like don't bought
and now I got a new girlfriend so when I
come there you know I want to be with
her you know I don't need them staring
and looking and judging get the [ __ ] out
of here you know put me on the list
list it's a [ __ ] house you understand
it's a little [ __ ] [ __ ] house that
I'm having fun I'm enjoying finally if
that like I made it like in 88 so it's
like 32 years ago like normally a guy
when they make it like at that point
they're done by 94 you know it would
just be over you know but I'm like which
Joey knows my career I'm like one of
those animals that just keep building it
so I'm finally at a point where I could
enjoy my shows you know what I mean like
I love like I mentioned in the stand and
governors and you know all these little
clubs that I'll stay on for an hour an
hour and a half because I'm enjoying the
craft of being a stand-up you know you
know and then you know you get like an
[ __ ] that wants to go well how come
you night at the garden this week you
know like that's not what I'm doing like
even when I did the Roseanne shows and
it and that was giant that I would look
at that as giant when you're in over
2,000 seats you know it was like 4,000
people that night and we didn't even put
4,000 seats on sale we put two on sale
but we did four out of you know they
asked you can we add can we yeah okay
great
and when I was up there it wasn't fun
for me it was work you know plus they
want to get people back in the casino
and instead of like drawing out the bits
you know and adding to them and making
it great you're just banging them over
the head and getting rid of them and I
don't like doing that you know I like
these smaller places and it's you really
like now I'm bringing I bring people
onstage I take pictures with them like
to the show if I happen to like them
because you tell them don't take out
your [ __ ] camera don't yell anything
out don't fell you're gonna get thrown
out like I had a thing at the Laugh
Factory a few weeks ago where I left the
stage mentally like on this one guy that
was just drinking and yelling and I said
I go this is now a personal thing to me
I go I go I'm not in the show right now
I don't [ __ ] like you and you're
gonna ruin the whole vibe
I said I will come there I'll grab you
by your throat and I'll throw you the
[ __ ] out of this room
I said say one more [ __ ] thing and
see what happened like I just lose it
because I don't want the three hundred
people that are there to not have a
great time because the one guy that can
hold this [ __ ] liquor it's not like
heckling thirty years ago where it was
fun and you bounce back and they're just
drunk they want to yell something in the
middle of a bit that makes no [ __ ]
sense and I just destroy him or have
them thrown out I enjoy getting rid of
fans you understand III know Fame is
basically new to you the last couple
years is where your star is risen you
know so it's new so you might actually
like to meet people like I tell them on
stage I go I'll give you everything just
don't come over to me if you see me in
the casino I don't want to meet you you
know I don't want to take a picture with
you that you're gonna tell me you're
gonna grab my shirt and go it's blurry
do another one I don't want to sign
anything I don't want to hear some
[ __ ] story that you're made-up or a
friend of mine that's not even a friend
that's been telling you for thirty years
he's a friend I don't want to hear it
you know I don't want to [ __ ] know
you I don't want you to follow me I
don't need you on Instagram to me as
like a goof like I do it for fun because
it's just there to do and I had I get
Eleanor like at her worst moments and I
film her and it nothing makes me happier
than to see her get angry at me you know
what I mean it's just an enjoyable part
of my day when I could aggravate her you
know and she's great at being aggravated
you know she hates her whole [ __ ]
life so if I see her mad at me I just
hit the camera and I get whatever I
could get out of her and so that's
enjoyable to me but to meet somebody in
here you know remember when you came out
with the palms ya know when you first
said and they start doing one I go I
don't need you to tell him I cut him off
like I don't let him go through with the
poem and said I don't want to hear my
I know my poem no but when you said no
but I don't want to hear it from you you
don't know how to do it you're an
[ __ ] guy you're 60 walk the [ __ ] away
no I'm not a people person I'd love to
be on stage but I don't want to meet
anybody because I know how most people
are no [ __ ] good and I know it
because I see him in there cause and I
see how these [ __ ] no good in
their [ __ ] hearts don't even bother
to use the blinker the closest thing
that's right there it tortures me on
people right there
why isn't me off and it's a law and
there is a fine you understand and they
could cause a lot of problems you know
people could get killed over this [ __ ]
like it's right there why not why didn't
you use it why didn't you use you blink
why why do you think making a u-turn
anywhere was acceptable why do you think
the guy pulling out of his spot wants to
choke you to die saw a guy make one that
I was illegal use and hit a car pulling
out from the other side of the Ventura
Boulevard fished in the guy's [ __ ]
dough you know I wanted to see that guy
get out of the car and kill him I really
wanted to see it and the guy that hit
him had no [ __ ] shoes forget about
the the flip-flops had no [ __ ] shoes
I wanted the guy that got hit to take a
pipe and just beat him to death and I
would have watched it like a TV show you
know because and I don't see any cops
stopping anybody doing this [ __ ] you
know what I mean just wherever you go
I'll make a u-turn here [ __ ] everybody
the rules in a road nobody's paying a
tenth the simplest thing a blinker you
know it upsets me too I hate when people
get in an accident they just stop right
in the middle of the freeway how about
on the train what happened to the Train
you know with a way you know they sit
down they put their bag in the middle so
yeah yeah and nobody wants to move their
[ __ ] bag
[ __ ] as you would say no [ __ ]
good and then when you ask them you mind
if I sit there and they make the face
like you're doing the wrong thing I paid
for a ticket [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] good piece of [ __ ] and
that's why audiences need to be treated
as I treat them look I'm not begging
them to come see me and I don't care if
anybody comes to see me I don't even
want them to you know but if if they're
gonna pay me money to be somewhere and
people want to pay to come I can't stop
them you know I'll entertain I'd be
happier with ten people a show you know
what I mean I could stay up even longer
no pressure but they keep showing up and
it keeps getting bigger and bigger now I
got this another and I was never gonna
go back to Australia you know so they
keep upping the money you know I'm like
you [ __ ] I hate them do you
understand like you know and everybody
go oh you'll have a good time it was he
I didn't have fun the first [ __ ] time
yeah all right I held the koala bear for
30 seconds I could have lived my whole
life out without ever holding one you
know what I mean because it's the whole
Ford Fairlane thing you know that I had
a koala bear so did everybody so I went
to a koala park and I held one and it
was very cute but believe me if I was 90
years old now and they go do you feel
bad you never held the koala bear no no
I don't like my dog the [ __ ] do I care
about a koala bear with my scribe two
people no pressure comedy pressure copy
yet pressure comedy because I lived a
lot of it is you know when I did these
bigger than life places and you know I
was never into the drugs or al-qaeda
dydt with a straight head so when you're
facing anywhere between 15 and 21
thousand people a night
there's a lot of pressure because number
one you feel them going through you and
that's what I felt in Atlantic City when
I did the Roseanne show like you feel
the energy of the crowd going through
you like it's it's just too much you
know and I train every day just about
but even back then when I was 30 I would
feel it you know and it was just too
much because I I did you know so many
toys it was you know it was hot you know
hundreds of shows like that and when
you're in a comedy club you know rather
when you're in a comedy club and
nobody's expecting you to be when you
just do a pop-up somewhere that's when I
feel no pressure at all you know it's
just like me and a living room full of
people even when I'm in a club you know
it's it's a small in volume and you know
you could really feel your laughs you
could really stretch out your material
whatever bit it might be and you come
off stage like pleased with yourself
because you got better at the bit and
you waited things to the bit you know
rather than having to be in front of a
big crowd and just bang them over the
head for 50 minutes or an hour and go
it's not the kind of show I want to do
you know that's the one thing I realized
when I did those shows with Rosie and I
go I don't need this I don't need to be
in these you know bigger than life
places it's just not what I want to do
you know and so I've been enjoying you
know the the biggest should be about
it's weird how you know theatres have
like rattlin 2019 hundred seats you know
so they could steal the other hundred
seats that they're not telling you about
right it's really mm but they you know
you got to let people steal their money
you know it's just how the business
works you know I remember a guy that had
a theater talking about what where's my
you know percent want you to make
percentage you know we gave a you know
90 tickets komm tickets you know you
know and I'm going what does that have
to do with me they're not 90 people for
me I don't even
I'm not friendly with 90 people you know
who am i given the tickets to
you know it's going why you didn't make
the percent like oh no but I did because
you gave those away you know it's on but
I don't get mad it's like that's just
part of the business you know that you
get ripped off
you know he's still walking away with a
bundle you know so I can't complain
about that but yeah I like being in a
smaller environment like you know when
I'm at the Trop in Vegas to me that's
like a home away from home The Laugh
Factory you know so that's why did I do
that like once every month want that
every other month and it's just
enjoyable to me so I get another finish
shooting another special if I did
another special it would be a the only
thing I got in my mind is almost like a
documentary slash special and and I'm
not talking about stage show clip stage
anybody doing that and I'm telling you
if you do like an hour don't ever leave
the stage meaning don't go to you know
Joey on the bus coming to town and then
back to stay it doesn't worry
it's like watch the stand-up special or
commercial you know I'll tell you the
truth I'll never forget when Pauly Shore
did his first special years ago and he
goes connect throw a concept that year
because I was already dice and doing
whatever I was doing because I'm gonna
do a special my first special and what I
want to do you know and he explained
like being on the bus and then cutting
to the stage and you know then showing
them with the fans and you know what
kinds of back to the state I go I
wouldn't do it that way you know I go
once you get I don't care if there's a
lead up to the stage I think that's good
you know but once you're on the stage
you don't cut away it's like when you
watch Comedy Central specials you get
into the guy or the girl there's a
command I got a commercial that's on
saying well that's when I you know go to
jerk my dick off and I'm not coming back
I'm just not coming back you know
once thinking once it's gone it's gone
like oh let me rev up to laugh again you
know I mean it doesn't work that way you
know you got once you run and and he's
going no well I want to do it this way
you know I love like if they give me
advice
I wanted to go so what the [ __ ] you were
gonna ask him me for know it still and
he did it that way and it was an awful
special you know not that paulie's awful
but it was an awful way to do things you
know it's like it just doesn't work so
if I do like the kind of project I want
to do it would be like because I got
hundreds of tapes of all that time and
it's like my son Max always says he goes
you're never gonna be explained the
right way till you explain it because
you know your story and you know how our
bumpy it's been and how rough it's been
their every move every move I've ever
made it's not come without the
aggravation it's just how the career and
life is gone and I don't mind that you
know it's just how it is though so but I
would know how to tell the story you
know nobody's you know who explains me
better you'll bleed oh you know Rogen
and I love when he does this when he has
a comic on because they don't want to
hear about anything of it in themselves
and for whatever reason Joe gets into
talking about me to a lot of these guys
and they don't want to hear it
they they're calm about it but they
don't want a [ __ ] and the calmer they
are the longer he talks about it it's
the greatest thing cuz people will call
me and go you got to see this clip from
Rogen because like like he talks about
you know how comics are doing arenas
today but he goes but dice when he did
it you know it was different it was it
was an explosion it was emotion you know
and but but he's got no he's not like
you know I love Howard Stern but even
Stern never laid it out the way Rogan
does you know because it was happening
when I was doing Stern Stern was coming
up you know he wasn't the Howard Stern
of today he was going city to city and
fighting all those guys in building his
career so I was the biggest thing in the
[ __ ] country and I had more
confidence than anybody I ever met in my
life so even he would never really give
it up like that you know but rogue you
know go and look when dice hit
it was like a bomb going off a bomb you
know and it's never happening again
don't lose that thought I gotta go pick
you totally all right it's time gonna
tell you what Ari has some great stories
about him opening for you and when you
were start talking about the audience he
has he told the story on his podcast
about someone asked to take a picture
with you yeah and he made an eye contact
with you and he just didn't get you in
the picture and the frame yeah he said I
was right they could do but wonder that
that was in the days where that what
cameras that you didn't have the instant
let me look at it right and more which I
can't [ __ ] take them so the comics at
the store knew when they take a picture
I'm not in it for the most part like you
might get a shoulder right yeah you
might get an ear but what was fun is
when like the person getting the picture
goes are you pointing the camera it
looks like the cameras a little too high
because you might get like the top of
their heads right yeah you know like I'd
love to see those pictures you know cuz
there's thousands of them out there
which is hysterical ohmmeter their arm
yeah and we used to just crack up
because it was like it's just you know
retake I mean if it was somebody that
was really nice and pleasant I would I
would say it like this echo if it was
Ari I go take a good picture like a nice
location yeah you know but if it was
some hard on some drunken [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I gotta say get your hands
off me you know what I mean cuz they get
very touchy you know you know they you
know I just look at him like you know
like I look up at the sky is something
and that's what the picture would be you
know like the moon you know and it's
just like a game you play just a little
game with the other calm that's so funny
I know I love all that stuff and that's
also when I started filming you know
everything you know with with the comics
and I call it the show and I come to
stop with my [ __ ] camera and everybody
had a pot like Ari was the antagonist
he's the one who ever you know this was
a whole new group of cats when you
started well you might have been there a
couple years before for 97 okay so you
know but it was re and Rena cz and Maz
Maz Jobrani was the falling comic you
know Mike Marino forever for whatever
reason we called the Russian you know
which is hysterical
Steve Simone was misery always in a bit
but like you'd see like are we talking
alike James painter let's say go what do
you what he talkin a dice for you know
you know he goes you know dices you know
I want to open for a night he's no way
he's done you know like re was always
that guy but he's also that guy in
reality you know how he is he bad
mouthed everybody you know like there's
a scene I got where are he's talking a
Sebastian and and Sebastian's going
what's dice doing with the camera you
know around the car and all he's like
you know he's just he's looking for
something to do you know what I mean you
know and what I'm gonna do I'm gonna put
the whole [ __ ] thing up on my youtube
channel
can you direct this or did you know I
direct okay oh the first scene with with
Maz Jobrani is hysterical cuz he's like
walking in the back parking lot you know
and I'm in my leather whatever I'm
smoking you know and I go hey you you
know he's going can I help you and I
know yeah
I hear you're like from the the middle
of something and he goes the Middle East
okay yeah well I'm from Brooklyn he goes
I might be coming there and I'm like oh
yeah and I'll be waiting and that's like
his first scene into the series that
never aired on anything it was the
unknown series it's hysterical
but everybody waited to film every night
that's that's why I became friendly with
Rogan cuz he would ask
like what what are you doing you know
you're kicking waitresses out of the
kitchen I go there in my shot you know
because what shot what show is this I go
it's just the show you know and he's
like did you change all those lights I
go yeah had to give it a mood ago it was
very stock lighting you know goes the
whole kitchens red you know I got red
and green that was a good colors
fulfillment you know or blue you know
yeah I changed all the [ __ ] bulbs
this is during Comedy Store I come up
behind the guy in the original room it
was perfect cuz I didn't know he's this
[ __ ] ugly
and Dave tail is on stage and I come in
I got the camera some seeing Taylor in
the back of this guy's head and I'm
going hey [ __ ] face I'm whispering
you know and there's no reason I go
[ __ ] face cuz I just wanted to call
that to somebody you know and this ugly
[ __ ] ugly never wins in this
world I gotta tell you the one of the
ugliest guys I have a [ __ ] saw it was
perfect
cuz when he turned around I'm like he
really does have a face like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I go you want to come with
me a minute you know and I take him
outside and I get him on film okaying I
go this is for my TV show you know so
you got to say your name and then it's
okay to use the footage because you're
part of the show now he's an audience
member they got paid to come into the
Comedy Store and I'm treating the whole
Comedy Store like it's my set you know
and it went on for months and months uh
my son Dylan who was nine tells off Ari
while they're playing that stupid game
up in the office they what does that get
boos ball foosball whatever the [ __ ]
that people waste their life on so you
know Ari's playing with Dylan Dylan's
nine years old you know and uh and our
he's like you know I don't think your
dad's funny you know he's playing the
game and Dylan's like what was that you
know and he goes I said I don't think
you're dead it's funny you know and
Dylan just goes
you ever play the forum you know like
just asking them questions did you ever
do the Mecca in Milwaukee you know and
always like what he goes have you ever
you know done multiple nights like Dylan
know a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] and he's
burying this man you know and always
looking at him going you know I work you
know and Dylan just throws like giant
[ __ ] things I did and then the next
scene is I grab Ari by his throat in the
kitchen because he took a piece of pizza
that I went out to get Eleanor if did
she swings at me that I can find her a
chicken sandwich because I was gone with
her at the time you know you know and
while she's screaming at me a whole lot
of love is on in the background and you
see different comics walking and
stopping like Sebastian you know
bewildered comes walking into that
kitchen like what the [ __ ] is going when
Assisi puts down boxes to seed that I'm
getting late and then it cuts to Mike
Marino you know going he's on the phone
he goes I gotta go
cuz he's the Russian and and that's the
end of the scene so by the time I got
the pizza you know I was just done so
when are we took a piece I just grabbed
him by the throat and slam him against
the wall go put the [ __ ] pizzas down
it's not your pizza because he's a pizza
thief you know so thirty years ago 1988
did you think you'd still be here 33
years later doing stand-up and then you
were doing those arenas what the [ __ ]
was born you're like one is this gonna
end when this is bad it's gonna end
does it ever end well I I did I remember
being like we were doing I think it was
the I called it to the max when Max was
born you know and it was a tour like I
had to come up with all these names to
and I go I'm good for this till about 40
that's how I looked like to do those
kinds
things that I didn't know what I wanted
to do you know and I was only like 32 at
the time something like that you know
it's just a lot you know and I'm going
like this kind of energy like to just
keep blowing this kind of energy out but
you know I knew I would do the stand-up
I I didn't know how I'd feel about it
but I'd be interviewed like that people
will go witty where do you see yourself
five years from now ten years ago ten
years from now and I would talk about
probably more movies you know that was
more were the going to be the stepping
stone of what I wanted to do but you
know I went through a lot of black black
boiling because of the controversy of
dice all the stuff that the comics are
dealing with today I went through alone
you know I was the only guy getting
attacked for my language and my subject
matter you know and the only one that
you know ever stood up for me was Eddie
Murphy you know every cop comics I know
that's why I say there's no [ __ ]
friends I'd see him on morning shows
bad-mouthing me come on buddies with
this [ __ ] you know it was
unbelievable to see all that go on but
it wasn't going on to the country it was
going on to me it was an attack on me
and I would just get angry and then I
would get nastier on stage you know like
like my game material back then was just
funny jokes but as the media kept
attacking I'm like well I'll just give
them what they want now you know and
that's where I came up with you know you
know like the jokes were funny because I
would talk about I don't even do it
anymore like what was the Kay jokes well
the train set like I talked about the
transgender thing today I go but years
ago I called them trains testicles you
know you meet the girl I said I would
talk about the gays and the boys and a
bisexual you either suck dick or you
don't suck dick what do you do wake up
in the morning flip a coin heads on one
hit by tails balls across the nose and
then you got these other things I
Godey's trains testicles you know was
this you meet the girl he dreams you
whine a diner take a home you put your
hand up a skirt you hold in a tree trunk
you know so back then the the half chick
wasn't popular
you know like nobody even knew what the
[ __ ] it was so I would get so people
would come after me for that you know so
now I do a whole bit with you know of
course a Caitlyn and that whole thing
and I go but when I discussed this years
ago you know I was just looked at like
what the [ __ ] is this you know but I saw
it all coming you know and I was just
under constant attack so then I add it
on I go and then you know when they get
the AIDS thing you know they can't
figure out where it came from
because now I'm angry at the press now
I'm gonna do nasty stuff course the
trans did the trans testicle the
bisexual so fun [ __ ] jokes but now I
go so then they get the AIDS oh I can't
figure out how I got to what do you mean
you can't figure it out
you're walking around with [ __ ] on your
dick you're bound to pick something up
you know and that's when the media would
go [ __ ] berserk on me cuz AIDS was
just happening and you know and I'm like
hey you're gonna [ __ ] come after me
like this I'm not gonna show you any
side of Andrew it's all dice now [ __ ] is
all when how did he stick up for you Oh
Eddie came out on Arsenio and said I
don't care what anybody says about him
he's the funniest guy that ever is I'm
going to see him at the forum you know
he it was it was pretty amazing cuz he
also pulled Eddie used to come over to
me gee I'm glad what's happening for him
now you know cuz he's the greatest
you know from movie star to comic just
the greatest I'm driving down Laurel
over Laurel Canyon like going towards
Melrose and Trinis with me and she goes
that's Eddie Murphy going he was in a
little Mercedes sports car convertible
and I'm in a 1970 Cadillac convertible
which you would love
you know and he's gonna pull over pull
over and I pull on a side street and
there's a million colors coming you know
was great like that would have made a
great picture you know yeah and she's
sitting in the car and then he gets out
going don't you let them [ __ ] with you
don't you let them [ __ ] cuz he used to
come over to me at the Comedy Store he'd
come there with 20 guys when he was you
know working on his stuff you know and
he'd walk away from his entourage he
just dug me you know and what I do and
then when I took off it baffled him like
he even said to me he goes how do you
draw twenty thousand people a night cuz
it just wasn't something comics did and
he's about as big as it would get he did
like if he did the garden he did like
his concert in the it was called the
Paramount at the time it's it's 6,000
seats Colin did a concert there did a
special there I did the guy I did the
sports arena I didn't do the the small
room which was amazing to do that room
but comics weren't thinking I'll go into
the big room you know I'll go into the
basketball arena so he goes how do you
sell 20,000 seats a night I go why do
your movies make you know 400 million
dollars I'll switch I'll switch any day
you want you know cuz he was amazing to
me you know and still is like I love
what I would call his resurgence now
course we all know Eddie Murphy doesn't
need money but if you're in this
business you like to be relevant you
know and like to me that was even the
thing when I took Rosana out with me
it's like she never has to work again as
far as money goes but what they did I
felt was just wrong with the network did
and she just wants to feel relevant so
that's why I started doing some shows
with her that Butte that was about you
watch the Dolomites yeah I watched half
of it and I loved it I was I loved it
was just you know my house is like an
after-hours Club my sons are up like all
night and we started watching the
Dolomites at 2:30 in the morning so you
know at about 3:30 I'm tired so I want
to you know go up you know get stoned
out
you know do you think I'll make it come
back
it does Daniel it's not even you know
what if I think he's one of the Great's
of all time I can't see I mean he won't
do that special until it's ready you
know but it's something I'm looking
forward to I think Andrew how are you
gonna get ready if you don't go out how
are you gonna get ready you can't do
stand up in front of the mirror I could
get Andrew Chris Rock louis c.k and
[ __ ] Nick DiPaolo and give you each
200 grand and give me 15 minutes of
material if I don't get up on stage and
work that material it's not gonna work
what Andrew are you talking about Eddie
yeah he's gotta work out he's got a war
I don't care what writers you get yeah
doesn't ease training where to Jim I
don't know what he's got in his house no
no I'm talking about standing O the
stand-up part getting in front of
thought how do you know where what he's
doing cuz I would be at the store if I
was him I don't know what areas I don't
that's what if the the minute Eddie
Murphy pops on a stage it's gonna be on
the front cover Yahoo look Eddie of the
microphone your mother it's a comedy
store Laugh Factory The Improv Bubba's
comedy house the black comedy club by
the airport okay if all these great
writers got together and wrote him an
hour you gotta practice
you gotta work did he say he's not gonna
practice I haven't seen him oh okay
so I'm saying to myself listen I'm I'm
here because of him in you I think I
mean because of him in you I don't think
you could just I wouldn't I wouldn't if
you gave me 70 million dollars for a
special I gotta [ __ ] give you the
best thing well I I talked about it I
think that um you know just knowing who
he is
I want like you could take the money and
run type of thing but I don't think
that's what it's about I think it's
about what I was talking
but the relevant the relevance
absolutely you know because you know
I've talked to him about like even when
he does like a rant in a movie like how
fast he would like deliver his dialogue
everything from 48 hours you know even
when he put it you know the movie he did
with Owen Wilson where he plays the
fighter like his monologues I I would
ask him like how do you do that you know
is it written is it ad-lib [ __ ] and he
goes you know you're an actor you do I
go no but it's your tempo like you lay
out like 10 pages in a minute you know
it's different than knowing like a
paragraph and then someone it's
different when it's these monologue he's
he's one of the greats
he's just one of the greats but I think
he'll deliver no matter where he gets it
ready I think he'll do no no I think
he'll deliver but he's got to get ready
I think when I asked you about no
pressure and pressure comedy is this I
shot two specials and I hated the
journey on boat oh yeah well that's
gonna have I hated looking back at it
now I [ __ ] hated the whole thing well
I did the Netflix thing when I got off
that stage I said something's got to
change
I don't like this and I came home and I
made a point I'm 55 years old
you can't take nothing away from me now
I'm going for it I don't want to shoot a
Netflix special I don't want to shoot an
HBO special do not I just wanna [ __ ]
do a stand-up people get mad at me why
don't you add shows why don't you sell
t-shirts because it's the law of
diminishing returns I don't want to
worry about a [ __ ] extra-large
nothing no more when I asked Andrew how
was your weekend in Connecticut and you
look at me and go make sure you go up
there you're gonna settle a lot of merch
so wait a second I'm mad if I [ __ ] these
shows and you're gonna talk to me about
merch I want you to talk to me about
your stand-up experience so I found too
many comics were worried about merch
always and it's [ __ ] pisses me the
[ __ ] off you want to know so when I go
into a city I don't want to do your
podcast
I'm telling you right now you're not
gonna get me to do your podcast because
when I get on a plane I got on a plane
to do standard who stand up exactly I
have a great [ __ ] time doing standing
well I will tell you like even the gigs
I'm going to do I don't bring t-shirts I
mean I know the stand is making up
shirts to sell whatever and that's okay
because I wear it on stage you know but
I'm not I don't I never really cared
with the merch you know what I mean
it doesn't really listen it my wife
sells says she says oh yeah that's great
I'm not bringing merch on me they were
Sund I hate the word mark I don't like
any of it when the comic comes out
Alliance I got a meet the PDA that goes
back to meeting the people and it's I
don't if I did sell merch you if I sell
merch look at this when you hit 98 it
was a different system no I had a day
that was it was all just a deal but no
no but you hit onward a [ __ ] Mouse
you and I had this discussion that would
you read for crime story he called you
when you were at West Orange at Rascals
that you had read and he did it
backwards and he called you 10 months
later and you hit it was [ __ ]
tremendous and that's why from then when
I started going into auditions I knew
they had the camera and you told me just
let the camera go and do [ __ ]
so that's how I started booking stuffing
yeah told me to start booking [ __ ]
but whatever e buddy's gonna read the
same lines and I read the same gotta
give him something a little that a
director goes oh I could direct this guy
you know what I mean so they watch John
crime story they saw this special you
tape from Philly there was no internet
there was no nothing today
this starts with a tweet Facebook
Instagram a podcast the completion of
the circle is them coming to see you and
then buying a shirt you shaking it yeah
that's the completion of the circle I
love to do that circle I love to do that
other than naughty shirt except I don't
want to soap to yet I don't mind going
out when I'm done with the show I like
to sit it cuz I'm burnt yeah I'm
that's what I'm trying to tell you just
want to fall on the couch you know the
agents want to call you that a show you
know what that second show they're not
gonna get but you know what I did I I
won't do two shows anymore a night I
would do even at a club but I did add a
second one you know I'm very close with
the the owner of governor's James so you
know I just got a text that you know
it's gone all the tickets are gone it's
only like what could it be close to 600
tickets you know so I said you want to
know cuz he asks would I do another one
the next night I just don't want to
decide you know what just add it the
Saturday night I'll do it but other than
that it's all one show a night wherever
I'm going
I wanted them to get the most the best
of me exactly and that's one show so
that's one shot not 34 no more
I can't guy shows in the [ __ ] week
and give you I can't do it how many did
I ask you to do
although I asked me to add like last
weekend they wanted me to add one in
Boston and I told bloomin rights no yeah
I just I told I did - I did - a town
hall and I'm doing one at [ __ ]
Chevrolet so you know what I don't like
doing - and - I'm gonna be tired every
hour [ __ ] you're trying right it's a
three hour train ride on Saturday plus I
got my family in New York I gotta talk
to my niece's my nephew's they're all
coming so when I get into Boston it's
4:00 in the afternoon my shows at 7:00
yeah those 9:30 people will get [ __ ] I
don't want to give them [ __ ] oh yeah -
oh yeah I didn't air their show how many
con major I'm a law of diminishing
returns you know you could just put so
much in you know like [ __ ] I'm not gonna
do Thursday's I'm leaving at 5:00 at
night get into your town Oh eleven
twelve eat something smoke some dope get
up and do four shows and get the [ __ ]
out yes even for sounds like a lock
today - and - or maybe one in one yeah I
like the one and I three nights is
pretty good I don't like one show a
night I like Thursday night off so I
could eat I could go see the town
sometimes you know it's a good schedule
sometimes you do a Wednesday take
Thursday off and do Friday Saturday
just one show and I but that's four
nights without my daughter
can't do it now oh I see what you're
saying let's see so you do three in a
row yeah so I like Thursday for I'd like
I'm doing Tempe Thursday Friday Saturday
else is just Friday have you been there
yet I'm going there and I happy Arizona
yeah I'm going I think in January improv
and one of Joel's rooms yeah your novel
yeah I love okapis one of my favorite
okay 20 years they tried to switch me to
Phoenix I don't want to go to Phoenix
[ __ ] temp you know the new one it's
the new one that no one is Phoenix I
don't know what that stand-up wine
that's 600 seats you know I like it it's
a great room it's a little bit too big
for my taste
you follow me yes a little bit too big
huh me and already sold it out I could
sell it out that's something problem
I like the Tempe improv threesome
okay yeah that's a great size a little
smaller you know the agents always want
money everybody's looking for money I
want them to have a good experience but
my honeys will be spend the money of
constant if I keep giving them good
experiences the money will always be
there yeah
it's supposed to run the career that you
want to have you know that's why when
you ask like what I want to do you know
I'm going yeah we'd do a dock slash
concert but in a club you know and
anybody that comes to me that's white um
I go I go it's part of the dock the last
half hour is part of a club set you know
I go that's how I would do it I go
that's the only thing like I'd want to
do if I should I'm doing a 25-minute set
in the mainland on YouTube saying that's
it
I love I have become you know I was
Mitzi's host for all those years and I
used to listen to her she used to say
little things to me 60% of the [ __ ] was
[ __ ] out of this world
craziness you know put on a fidel beard
a handcuff oh yeah you know she loved
that [ __ ] use how to avoid her but she
tell you something once a month and
after she died and after what I happened
in Vegas with Netflix I just decided I
just go to the store now well what
happened with the Netflix I just didn't
when I was wanted to do I was working
out the wrong places I should have been
at the store because metal sharpens
metal uh-huh I didn't want people to see
the material I you know I got into my
head I watched John mulaney's special
all of a sudden I'm thinking I should be
John Mulaney and be clean I want a girl
you went through this I went through
this whole thing for no reason and I got
on that plane from Vegas and I changed
everything around and you ask Alan at
the store now whatever comes out of my
mouth comes out of my mouth I could care
less
so let's give you pressure to clean it
up was no no not at all Netflix didn't
ethically it was me it was a faulty
wiring it can't be anything but you yes
what it's suppose I have a what I didn't
do and now what I don't even I never
watched that full special I watched like
the first eight minutes when it came on
Netflix I shut off and I swore that that
person would never come back again
when I go up there now I'm a bolt to
[ __ ] lightning I don't give a [ __ ]
what comes out and I like the original
room you like the man I don't know I
loved the original that's my route like
but there's so much action now in the
main room that I've gotten good into me
yeah I just did to me that's like doing
a concert yeah man the main rooms like
it's big you got a big no but I'd rather
be but it's training it also trained me
for theatres you know better in theaters
I'll be doing a lot I'm an original room
guy yeah I'll live in that when I get my
wait is it the original role all right
okay there's no veneer funeral but only
gotta go to the morbid stuff because
it's the truth I want to be buried under
the [ __ ] stage at the original room
all right like you know I'm saying wait
a minute I think we got again we got a
guest
we got the nod cast at Ellen yeah who
did she want to meet who's this cute
little girl this is my daughter and you
put put that thing God or something okay
I got her some that's right look like
that I never I never share my candy
because I love candy what's your name
Marcy how old you six-and-a-half look at
you you look like you just get what kind
of class were you just uh here come
closest uh yeah yes so you can tell the
people Mercer
so I am my class was just move aside
Mike and it's called team bully Busters
it's like like we don't really earn
Phelps tier because it's not really
their thing what did you like to keep
bullies away right yeah show show with
mom mama put the targets keep going neon
kicking the kick with the right foot the
macro six years old and you could do
that aye-aye sir I won't mess with you I
might hire you to be a bodyguard though
[Music]
alright that's it nothing that doesn't
it make you jealous that she's not out
of breath mmm it's amazing
nothing well for that little display you
win the award of a giant tootsie roll
does that sound good
yeah that's real say thank you uncle
Andrew now what do you know uncle and
your phone a star is born is he your
favorite in the star is born I can't
believe that there's one of the songs I
know called Stalin dare I remembered a
song you like that song ah you like Lady
Gaga I'm Bradley but he was your
favorite right that's that's funny to me
what made you my favorite why am I the
favorite like because when my parents
just said that you are silly
um alright
it is very unlike like was my favorite
character Wow
that well so it's so great to me I'm
glad you came over here yeah no problem
is that we just said that's historical
you know and how you doing I haven't
seen you forever amazing you look great
by the way
yeah I know your parents for a long time
long time like we you know I was like I
think nine years old when I met you dad
[Laughter]
but for a long time 30 years around that
you know what I mean yeah when my hair
was black but like for real before but
number one I showed you his stand-up he
did the the nursery rhymes nursery rhyme
I can't believe he let you watch that
nobody you know you know you know an
agent saw cuz are your dad and
everything so my agent when I met his
son he was only five years old and he
had all of those memorized like and my
agent was gonna go ahead do another one
you know do another one and and what was
funny is that his Bar Mitzvah this kid's
Jarrod offers his name I made a tape
where I'm wearing the dice rules jacket
and I thanked Jarrod for the bit that
put me over the top and then you see him
in my kitchen because I'd film
everything doing the poems at five years
old like almost like he's teaching me
the poems you know and now he's 35 years
old yeah and there's your jacket she
does a podcast on Tuesdays Andrew it's
called science with mercy and this week
we did your girl I could say pretty yeah
you got to know all that bully stuff
keep all the guys away for you know want
to grow up first
just keep learning that you're really
good with that stuff know the kicks
everything you got to protect your
father you know I mean so you do a lot
of different classes so the swimming
there's the jiu-jitsu what else what
else you like to do violin you were to
play how long you been playing violin
kindergarten wow so cute so she's the
cutest thing this is what happens I
can't I can't even believe it we'll have
to you know we'll have to take a picture
so you'll have a picture you know you
let your mom you got your phone let's
take we'll take some yeah we got with
the microphone the whole show business
thing right good come on in ladies and
gentlemen this is podcast sister but
she's so amazing she's been dying to do
this you have no idea oh she knows oven
yeah
[Laughter]
so you're at the stand tomorrow night
I'm at the stand tomorrow I'm at the
stand on the seventeenth and eighteenth
tickets are on sale we added a show a
governor's on the 14th we're all so am I
gonna play over there Oh Lord oh Vinny's
okay you know what about flour your all
your ear and there why do you keep
bringing I'm sorry why I'm Jewish
all right well that's this you know
Florida happened
okay I'm sorry talk again some
Wunderland did you see them the movie is
on well I think it's also on HBO and
just watch last night just watch the new
one would you like the newest version
all right Johnny Depp did the one we
watch that one yeah night you like
Johnny Depp I know him you know that I
know him if I see him I'll tell him
you're a fan of his I'll tell you if I
know them who's that
yeah she's got to change her name
and Lady Gaga Lady gaga right okay and
their plane next week at the Forum
you're taking her she asked but I can't
take it to the forum
they're animals down there
I'll do it when I'm a teenager she's
ready to go yeah yeah she's just she's
full of personality to sit you're
amazing really yeah you know all right
you got good Terence
did that teaching and the right things
you know my parents only taught me to
wear the fingerless gloves you know they
said and live you gotta live in warm
weather if you're gonna wear fingerless
gloves when I was something you said
that again I took your lead
well what handshaking no no what you
were talking about how you took a
breather because you wanted to raise
your kids and I think that yeah I have
two sons a lot of people in Hollywood
and we've known a lot of them have kids
as comedians and you see the kids 20
years they make it to a jack that they
messed up you know what's going on I
didn't want that to happen if you don't
bring your kids up or teach them you
know what you do in life that's how I
really look at that not that's what I do
that's why to this day to this day you
know you got the parenting never end
never ends you know I will just to get
someone for that and you to be home with
her yeah you say that you got a good
daddy you really do here come to come
close to get so you could talk to the
people so he told me every he told me
everything about his life so when he was
saying Vaughn dogs and his mom only
taught them not to do it but he keep
doing it him he added to take his toys
to a person that was a boy a young boy
that was not only homeless I remember
that he actually do you like them I
found and all whoa
oh yeah he lives down the hall it's my
girl I have
on my phone you do who else roasty like
I also like crazy train how's the
Osborne I would say scorpions Wow well
next time his boys have a rehearsal
maybe we'll take you Oh welcome to the
jungle
that's right Guns N'Roses there's my
boys of a rock band my sons
yeah so maybe you go see him right there
called no one cares so you tell your
father get some of that music for you
you'll like yeah well this was a very
family fun yeah just for Ian Taylor
Spartacus does the Christmas dice the
first part of this podcast like how
naughty say wave to your fans
Makena watch this the Kiva's 105 from
the second right Sanaa hey let me wrap
this up my little angel love that this
was great I mean I'm going to get
together Day holiday the holiday but
this is it the holiday dice is how they
podcast I'll of you okay
so Tuesday tomorrow night here at the
stand tomorrow night next week you're at
the stand next week again I keep looking
at the day 17th and 18th you know and
then the rest is like gone you know
everything's gone you know well I hope
you come on in six months thank you
so always thank you for Jesus thank you
for always being a great mentor thank
you I have followed your footsteps
and then you're doing amazing and I'm
just happy that you're still around I
love you on my arm thank you
tomorrow night the stand next week the
stand I'm at the ice house the 21st book
Christmas with uncle Joey
and then Colusa the 27th and San
Francisco Performing Arts Center I think
on the 28th go on the website and
without that I'll see you savages
Wednesday I want to thank the legend the
heavyweight king of undisputed king of
comedy Andrew Dice Clay what I think
mercy Diaz I want to thank the
[ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys for supporting and the whole thing
I'll see you guys Wednesday stay black
and now for a word from our sponsors all
right I want to thank dice I want to
thank my daughter mercy for crashing the
show my wife and I want to thank you
guys but before that I want to talk to
you about a few things I don't know if
you've heard about Martin Scorsese's new
epic movie the Irishmen starring Robert
De Niro I'm Pacino and Joe Pesci and my
brother Sebastian Maniscalco is crazy
Joe gallo if you haven't seen the
Irishman yet go watch it okay
you'll hear from Charlie Brandt the
author of I heard you paint houses find
out how he uncovered Frank Sheeran story
learn why DeNiro fell in love with the
book and how they got Joe Pesci out of
retirement get inside the look of the
tricks they used to da's the cast behind
the Irishman is hosted by a member of
the Church family of my brother ham one
of the stars of the movie Sebastian
Maniscalco so do me a favor the first
two episodes are out in the final
episode is coming out next Monday
spoiler alert spoiler alert spoiler
alert watch the Irishmen first on
Netflix before you listen to the podcast
13 million people can't be wrong the
movies tremendous search for behind the
Irishmen on Apple products Apple
podcasts Spotify stitcher pocket cast or
wherever else you listen to podcast
watch the movie then go behind the
Irishmen the church is also brought to
you by listen there's the best Christmas
present you give a man all right you
ladies are sitting there what am i
leaving my boy from
my husband this is it manscape you're
gonna give them the lawnmower 2.0 it's
called a lawn mow 2.0 for a reason they
threw away the on point O the 1.0 and
they upgraded the trimmer with skin save
technology for you mow mows in the back
that means it won't snick or snag your
nutsack
you want them to lick your nuts you
gotta shave that [ __ ] thing is not it
smells like [ __ ] dead ahh --mess
manscape makes a great gift for any guy
trust me grandpa
your dad your boyfriend your husband
place one order and take care everything
you need with the perfect package you
get the lawn mower and the safety razor
plus they're gonna throw in the crop
preserver deodorant for your nutsack and
the revival it's like the the CGI in in
the Irish when it takes the wrinkles out
of your nutsack it's a sprint that tones
and refreshes your [ __ ] nuts and it
keeps you cool with the perfect package
you'll be smooth as a snowman what are
you waiting for a dog right now the
church family gets 20% off your first
order when you use promo code church at
manscape com order the perfect package
with the code church and they'll even
throw on a free travel bag which I use
it's tremendous I carry the the
manscaped in that a 2.0 I charge it on
the road I trim my nuts on the road it's
tremendous but remember use promo code
Church that's manscape calm use promo
code church for 20% off your first order
get manscaped and keep your balls clean
I want to thank dice my daughter and all
you guys and the rest of the church
family for supporting us we'll see you
Wednesday all right take this
[ __ ] Mele League